former Vice President Joe Biden heads to
Iowa this morning after launching his
campaign for the Democratic presidential
nomination
Biden held his first rally yesterday in
the swing state of Pennsylvania reaching
out to traditional Democratic voters ed
O'Keefe covered that rally in Pittsburgh
Edie good morning although I also heard
him mention the independence absolutely
the Biden campaign has just released a
video using President Obama's words and
voice to tell the story of Biden's
career it's not an endorsement but a
sign he plans to tout his
accomplishments and back out on the
campaign trail for himself for the first
time in about a dozen years Biden went
hard at President Trump Donald Trump is
only president is the only president
who's decided not to represent the whole
country the president has his base we
need a president who works for all
Americans in his first campaign rally
Biden was clear about the need for
Democrats to win back Pennsylvania if
I'm gonna be able to beat Donald Trump
in 2020 it's gonna happen here in 2016
president Trump pulled off a surprising
win in the state that voted for Barack
Obama in 2008 and 2012 I make no
apologies
I am a union man Biden strong support
with working-class Americans and labor
unions could be key to also winning back
Michigan and Wisconsin two states that
went Republican in 2016 the stock market
is roaring but you don't feel it on the
economy the former vice president made
an emotional appeal there's two trillion
dollar tax cut like last year did you
feel it did you get anything from it of
course not of course not all it went to
folks at the top clearly the president
is paying attention on Twitter he mocked
sleepy Joe Biden and pointed out that
Pittsburgh is having one of the best
economic years in its history in fact in
March Pennsylvania's unemployment rate
dipped to three point nine percent the
lowest level since 1976
one other thing Biden did Monday he once
again apologized for how he handled the
1991 Senate Judiciary Committee hearings
with Anita Hill who had accused now
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas of
sexual harassment
but even folks in the crowd are
trying to move on they said that it
wasn't Biden who had harassed Anita Hill
was Clarence Thomas now when people you
talk to him wasn't so an issue for them
interesting yeah so as far as launches
go how did he do pretty good you know
decent sized crowd predominantly union
members several had been in the Union
for 40 years but they said they're happy
to hear it and disputed the president's
suggestion the rank-and-file union
members aren't likely to support Biden
they said no we're we're more likely to
support by and then Trump all right
we'll see now it begins again Thank You
Eddie